This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the artsy neighborhood of Echo Park in Los Angeles, right across the street from Echo Park Lake, you'll find a building that begs to be noticed. It sits against the backdrop of coffee shops, tattoo parlors, and tattoo parlors-clash-coffee shops. It's a colossal white structure that looks like an arena laced with archways. Its defining feature is an enormous concordering. concrete dome perched overhead. The building itself is a blend of classical and modern design
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。在洛杉矶充满艺术气息的艾科公园街区，就在艾科公园湖的街对面，你会发现一栋让人无法忽视的建筑。它与咖啡馆、纹身店以及那种夹杂在咖啡馆里的纹身店为邻，背景相衬。这是一座宏伟的白色建筑，看起来像是一座带有拱门的竞技场。它最显著的特征是头顶上方有一个巨大的混凝土圆顶。这座建筑本身融合了古典与现代的设计
elements and has been described as, quote, half Roman Coliseum, half Parisian opera house. I mean, some people have described it that way. But if you ask me, I think it looks more like a concrete flying saucer landed on top of the Rose Bowl Stadium. Best reporter, actor, and frequent contributor, Gillian Jacobs. One of my personal nerdier hobbies is driving around Los Angeles and looking up the history of buildings. It's what I do to relax. So, of course, the first time I went to Echo Park Lake, I homed in on that building across the street. I had to know what it was.
元素，曾被形容为“一半是罗马斗兽场，一半是巴黎歌剧院”。我是说，有些人确实是这么形容的。但如果你问我，我觉得它看起来更像是一个混凝土飞碟降落在了玫瑰碗体育馆的顶部。特约记者、演员兼常驻撰稿人吉莉安·雅各布斯。我个人比较书呆子的爱好之一，就是开车环游洛杉矶，并查阅建筑的历史。这是我放松的方式。所以，理所当然地，我第一次去艾科公园湖时，我的注意力就锁定在了街对面的那栋建筑上。我必须知道那是什么。
And luckily for me, there are tours available. The dome was also the largest freestanding dome of that size and shape, at least in the northern hemisphere, if not the world, at the time. Turns out this place is a Pentecostal church called the Angelus Temple. Dan Scott is head docent of the Temple's Heritage Museum. Seated 5,300 people. It was also uniquely built. It's completely fireproof. So that's why it's never burned down all these years.
对我来说幸运的是，那里提供参观游览。这个圆顶也是当时至少在北半球（如果不是全球的话）同等大小和形状中最大的独立式圆顶。事实证明，这个地方是一个名为“安吉拉斯教堂”的五旬节派教堂。丹·斯科特是该教堂遗产博物馆的首席讲解员。它能容纳5300人。它的建造方式也很独特。它是完全防火的。所以这就是为什么这么多年来它从来没有被烧毁过。
The temple was designed by the church's founder, Sister Amy Semple McPherson. Her voice was actually playing through the museum speakers throughout the tour. What you hear in the background, our live church service. that were broadcast live from the temple. I'm going to turn her off for a while. Sometimes I feel like I'm competing with her. As it happens, the Angeles Temple isn't just an architectural anomaly in Echo Park. It's regarded as the very first megachurch ever built in the United States.
这座教堂由教堂的创始人艾米·森普尔·麦克弗森修女设计。在整个参观过程中，博物馆的扬声器里实际上一直在播放她的声音。你在背景中听到的是教堂的现场礼拜，这些礼拜是从教堂现场直播的。我要把它关一会儿。有时我觉得我是在和她竞争碰瓷。碰巧的是，安吉拉斯教堂不仅是艾科公园的一个建筑异类，它还被视为美国建造的第一座超级教堂。
The temple was opened in 1923, which predates the modern megachurch movement by about a half a century. Today, when millions of Americans enter contemporary megachurches with all of their accompanying theatrical accoutrements, they unknowingly enter spaces pioneered by Amy Semple McPherson. So much about what you see in megachurches today and Christian broadcasting and entertainment, Christian fiction, all of that is, you know, these things that she started. This is Claire Hoffman, author of Sister Sinner, the Miraculous Life and Mysterious Life. disappearance of Amy Semple McPherson. As you can imagine from the title of Claire's book, there's a lot more to McPherson's story than just being a preacher.
这座教堂于1923年开放，比现代超级教堂运动早了大约半个世纪。今天，当数百万美国人带着所有随之而来的戏剧化装备走进当代的超级教堂时，他们不知不觉地进入了由艾米·森普尔·麦克弗森开创的空间。你在今天的超级教堂、基督教广播和娱乐、基督教小说中看到的很多东西，所有这些，你知道的，都是她开创的。这是克莱尔·霍夫曼，著有《修女、罪人：艾米·森普尔·麦克弗森的奇迹与神秘一生》一书的作者。正如你从克莱尔书名中想象的那样，麦克弗森的故事远不止是一个传道人那么简单。
McPherson transformed worship and at one point was arguably one of the most famous women in America. She built one of the largest churches in the country and filled it with thousands of people a week. She also stirred up one of the most salacious public dramas of the early 20th century. You know, she was making some decisions and mistakes that were pretty questionable themselves. And so here's a really complicated person who was incredible and powerful and also made some really weird choices. Before she added The Semple and McPherson, Sister Amy was born Amy Kennedy in 1890. Here she is talking about growing up in rural Canada. It was some distance away on a Canadian farm in Ontario that I was born and brought up as a farmer's daughter.
麦克弗森改变了礼拜仪式，在某个时期，她可以说是美国最著名的女性之一。她建造了国内最大的教堂之一，每周吸引成千上万的人前来填满它。她还煽动了20世纪初最耸人听闻的公共丑闻之一。你知道的，她做出了一些本身就很可疑的决定和错误。所以这是一个非常复杂的人，她既令人难以置信、充满力量，同时也做出了一些非常奇怪的选择。在她加上“森普尔”和“麦克弗森”之前，艾米修女于1890年出生时名叫艾米·肯尼迪。这里是她讲述自己在加拿大乡村长大的经历。我出生并在安大略省的一个加拿大农场长大，那是离那儿有一段距离的地方，作为一个农场主的女儿。
I was the only boy on the farm, the only girl on the farm. By even her own account, Amy was an overachiever during her schoolgirl years. In her own writings, she describes herself as top of her class, a natural leader, debater, elucionist, and always looking for an opportunity to perform. Amy came from a religious family. Her mother, Minnie, was a devout member of the Salvation Army. And Amy had her own divine experience when she was 17 years old. She met this super hot preacher named Robert Semple,
我是农场里唯一的男孩，农场里唯一的女孩。甚至按照她自己的说法，艾米在学生时代也是一个超越自我的人。在她自己的著作中，她将自己描述为班级名列前茅、天生的领袖、辩论家、演说家，并且总是在寻找表演的机会。艾米来自一个宗教家庭。她的母亲明妮是救世军的虔诚成员。艾米在17岁时有了自己的神圣体验。她遇到了一个超级性感的传道人，名叫罗伯特·森普尔，
who was an early convert of Pentecostalism. Amy fell deeply in love with the super hot preacher Robert Semple and with Pentecostalism. In the early 20th century, Pentecostalism was a new Protestant religious movement. that was beginning to spread across the U.S. At the time, it was viewed as fringe within mainline Christianity, mostly because of its more dramatic elements. Faith healing and the speaking in tongues. This is William Schultz,
他是五旬节运动的早期皈依者。艾米深深地爱上了这个超级性感的传道人罗伯特·森普尔，也爱上了五旬节运动。在20世纪初，五旬节运动是一场刚刚开始在全美传播的新新教宗教运动。当时，它在主流基督教中被视为边缘派系，主要是因为它有更多戏剧化的元素。信心疗法和说方言。这是威廉·舒尔茨，
assistant professor of American religions at the University of Chicago Divinity School. In back of those specific things is the general idea of Pentecostalism, which is that everyone needs a need, infilling of the Holy Spirit. You need to open yourself up to this force beyond you, the Holy Spirit, which will flow into you and transform you, make you an entirely new person.
芝加哥大学神学院美国宗教专业助理教授。在这些具体事情的背后，是五旬节运动的一般理念，那就是每个人都需要一种需求，即圣灵的充满。你需要向超越你的这种力量——圣灵——敞开心扉，它会流入你体内并改造你，使你成为一个全新的人。
Pentecostalism was looked down upon by many at the time. Followers were even disparagingly called holy rollers because when that infilling of the Holy Spirit took place, some worshippers would uncontrollably roll on the ground during services. But Amy was deeply moved by this form of worship. She converted to Pentecostalism and soon she and Robert Semple were married and expecting a child. Together they embarked on an evangelical tour to China, hoping to spread Pentecostalism to the other side of the world. Pentecostalism would become a huge part of the rest of her life. Robert, however, he died within a month of them arriving in China. Amy married again a couple of years after returning to the United States, becoming Amy
当时五旬节运动被许多人看不起。追随者甚至被贬损地称为“圣洁滚地者”，因为当圣灵充满发生时，一些崇拜者会在礼拜期间无法控制地在地上打滚。但艾米被这种形式的崇拜深深打动了。她皈依了五旬节运动，不久她和罗伯特·森普尔就结婚了，并期待着一个孩子的降生。他们一起踏上了前往中国的福音宣教之旅，希望能将五旬节运动传播到世界的另一端。五旬节运动将成为她余生中极其重要的一部分。然而，罗伯特在他们抵达中国一个月内就去世了。回到美国几年后，艾米再次结婚，成为了艾米·
Semple McPherson. But she quickly realized that this second marriage wasn't her path. She fell into a depression that severely impacted her mental and physical health to the point that she was hospitalized. And in the midst of this traumatic period, she had an epiphany. She says that Jesus came to her and said, you know, you have to, you have to spread the word. And this is your job. So McPherson answered the call. She left husband number two, packed her kids and her mom into her car, and began a new life as a traveling preacher on what was called the Sawdust Trail. The Sawdust Trail wasn't a literal trail with a set path. Rather, roving pastors, who were almost exclusively men, would travel from city to city in town to town, holding boisterous revival
森普尔·麦克弗森。但她很快意识到这第二段婚姻并不是她的归宿。她陷入了抑郁，这严重影响了她的身心健康，甚至到了住院的地步。在这段创伤时期的中间，她有了一次顿悟。她说耶稣来到她身边并说道，你知道的，你必须，你必须传播这个词。这是你的工作。于是麦克弗森回应了召唤。她离开了第二任丈夫，把她的孩子们和妈妈塞进汽车，作为一名四处奔波的传道人开始了新生活，走上了所谓的“锯末小径”。“锯末小径”并不是一条有着固定路线的字面意义上的小径。相反，几乎全由男性组成的四处流动的牧师们会在一个又一个城市、一个又一个城镇之间穿梭，举行喧闹的复兴
meetings. So with the Sawdust Trail, it's a really competitive marketplace. There are hundreds, thousands of itinerant revivalists. And so you are in a constant state of competition with other people. Many of these other preachers on the circuit evangelized in a sort of testosterone-laden, aggressive style. America needs to be taken down to God's bathhouse and the hose turned on her. And I want to take a pledge in this audience to join me in a pledge that you will never rest until this old God-hating, Christ-hating, whiskey-soaked, Sabbath-breaking, blaspheming, infidel, bootlegging old world is bound to the cross of Jesus Christ by the golden chains of love.
聚会。所以伴随着锯末小径，这是一个竞争非常激烈的市场。有成百上千、上万名四处游走的复兴主义者。所以你处于与其他人的持续竞争状态中。巡回布道中的许多其他传道人都采用了一种充满雄性激素的、极具侵略性的风格。美国需要被带到上帝的澡堂里，用水管冲洗她。我想在这群观众中做一个承诺，与我一起发誓，你们永远不会罢休，直到这个古老的仇恨上帝、仇恨基督、浸泡在威士忌里、破坏安息日、亵渎神明的异教徒、走私私酒的旧世界，用爱的金链子捆绑在耶稣基督的十字架上。
Sister Amy's message was nothing like that. She had all of the charisma and theatricality, but a gentler message. Amy packages, for lack of a better word, a really domestic style, which you don't see among many people on the sawdust trail. This is my past to love someone more dearly every day, to help a one-thing child to find his way, to ponder or a mobile thought and pray and smile when evening falls. This is my past.
艾米修女的信息完全不同。她拥有所有的个人魅力和戏剧性，但传达的信息更温和。借用一个不太恰当的词，艾米打包了一种非常家庭化的风格，你在锯末小径上的许多人身上是看不到这种风格的。这是我的过去：每天更深地爱一个人，帮助一个迷途的孩子找到他的路，去思考一个转瞬即逝的想法并祈祷，在夜幕降临时微笑。这是我的过去。
She emphasizes her connection with people. this image of a simple country person, a milkmaid, who has been infused with this divine power. And this might be the thing, which allows Amy to rise out of this very competitive religious marketplace. McPherson intuitively knew how to reach people and used whatever mass media tools were at her disposal. At first, she used a megaphone. and then started a monthly magazine. With her success, she wasn't just popularizing her ministry. She was popularizing Pentecostalism itself. One of the foundational leaders of American Pentecostalism was a black pastor named William Seymour.
她强调她与人们的联系。这种朴素的乡村女子、挤奶女工的形象，被注入了这种神圣的力量。这可能正是让艾米能够从这个竞争激烈的宗教市场中脱颖而出的原因。麦克弗森凭直觉知道如何触及人们，并利用她所掌握的任何大众媒体工具。起初，她使用扩音器，
Seymour wanted to create an interracial church where congregants of any race could worship together. But by 1914, segregation caused the denomination to split. There's the sort of the white Pentecostal movement and the African American, and they're both pretty fringy. Amy Simple McPherson began ministering around the time of this split and popularized the predominantly white version of Pentecostalism to the masses. I have compared her both sort of positively and negatively to Elvis. She made it a spectacle. She made it palatable. You don't mean she made it white.
然后创办了一份月刊。随着她的成功，她不仅在推广她的事工。她还在推广五旬节运动本身。美国五旬节运动的奠基领袖之一是一位名叫威廉·西摩的黑人牧师。西摩希望创建一个跨种族教堂，任何种族的会众都可以在一起礼拜。但到1914年，种族隔离导致该教派分裂。有某种白人五旬节运动和非裔美国人运动，而且它们都非常边缘化。艾米·森普尔·麦克弗森正是在这次分裂前后开始传道，并将主要是白人版本的五旬节运动普及给大众。我曾把她既褒且贬地比作猫王。她把它变成了一场奇观。她让它变得平易近人。你不是指她把它变白了吧。
So all the things that like kind of popularizing does. the way that Elvis did with the blues, right? So it's like, you know, the origins are very much elsewhere, but she was sort of this bridge. In 1918, after three years of making a name for herself on the sawdust trail, McPherson's profile had grown, but the endless traveling was beginning to wear on her. After her daughter nearly died from the 1918 flu,
所以所有类似于普及所做的事情。就像猫王对待布鲁斯音乐那样，对吧？所以就像是，你知道的，起源完全在其他地方，但她某种程度上就是这座桥梁。1918年，在锯末小径上闯出名堂三年后，麦克弗森的知名度有所提高，但无休止的旅行开始让她感到疲惫。在她的女儿在1918年流感中差点丧生之后，
McPherson claimed that she was called by God to head west and build a permanent church. And that church would be in Los Angeles. It was a decision that ultimately would reverberate, not just through the city, but the future of American Christianity. Los Angeles, in many ways, was the perfect fit for Amy Semple McPherson.
麦克弗森声称她受到了上帝的召唤，要向西进发并建造一座永久的教堂。而那座教堂将座落在洛杉矶。这个决定最终将产生深远的影响，不仅波及这座城市，还将影响美国基督教的未来。在很多方面，洛杉矶都是艾米·森普尔·麦克弗森的完美契合点。
For one, the city was playing a pivotal role in the rise of Pentecostalism because it's where William Seymour's revival was located. But also, L.A. in 1918 was a small but rapidly growing city packed with Christian migrants from the Midwest and South. It was a place looking for spiritual guidance. Not long after arriving in Los Angeles, McPherson and her mother found an empty lot for sale across from Echo Park Lake. She felt this was where her church should be built. She imagined her temple to be a grand coliseum-like neoclassical structure with a soaring dome overhead.
一方面，这座城市在五旬节运动的兴起中扮演了关键角色，因为威廉·西摩的复兴运动就位于这里。但同时，1918年的洛杉矶是一个规模虽小但迅速发展的城市，挤满了来自中西部和南部的基督教移民。这是一个正在寻找精神指导的地方。来到洛杉矶不久后，麦克弗森和她的母亲在艾科公园湖对面找到了一块待售的空地。她觉得她的教堂应该建在这里。她想象她的帝国像一个宏伟的、具有斗兽场风格的新古典主义建筑，头顶上有个高耸的圆顶。
And while those combination of words generally conjure a very specific type of macho architecture, She built this structure to mirror her femininity. It looks like a wedding cake to me. It's got a lot of gilded, soft, floral edges to it. It's a version of power, you know? Like, you know, you see some buildings and it's obvious that they are supposed to be signifying, like, power and permanence. But I think there is this thing where you don't see that many buildings that have so much money poured into them that are so female. McPherson and her mother Minnie were able to work out a unique deal with a construction
虽然这些词语组合通常会让人联想到一种非常特定类型的硬汉建筑，但她建造这座结构是为了映射她的女性气质。在我看来它就像一个结婚蛋糕。它有很多镀金的、柔和的、花卉边缘。这是一种权力的版本，你知道吗？就像，你知道的，你看到一些建筑，很明显它们本意是要象征权力和永恒。但我认为有这样一种情况，你很少看到有这么多资金倾注进去、且如此女性化的建筑。麦克弗森和她的母亲明妮得以与一家以在全市建造电影宫殿而闻名的建筑公司达成一项独特的协议。
company that was famous for building movie palaces around the city. They allowed her to pay in installments and build whatever they could afford incrementally. McPherson would travel around holding revivals to raise funds and they would construct parts of the temple piecemeal as the money came in. I believe she bought the property by Echo Park in 1921. There was a little story in Angeles Times that was like, Lady Evangelist has big ideas, you know? And, yeah, two years later, she opens the largest church in America. Oh, I wish that you might know the joy of it. The preaching the gospel, the seeing the thousands wending their way down the altars to kneel at the feet of Jesus, they're crucified.
他们允许她分期付款，并根据他们能够承受的经济能力逐步建造任何部分。麦克弗森会到处旅行举行复兴会来筹集资金，随着资金的到来，他们会一块一块地建造教堂的部分。我相信她是在1921年买下了艾科公园的这处房产。《洛杉矶时报》上有一则小故事，上面写着“女传道人有宏伟的想法”，你知道的。而且，是的，两年后，她开设了美国最大的教堂。哦，我多么希望你能知道其中的喜悦。传扬福音，看到成千上万的人蜿蜒走向圣坛，跪在被钉十字架的耶稣脚前。
And now, after all of these years, they've come to crown our labor's beautiful Angela's temple. On New Year's Day of 1923, McPherson opened the Angeles Temple, home to the ministry that she named the Four Square Church. Inside, there was a room for performing miracle cures, a watchtower that acted as a round-the-clock prayer room, a room dedicated to speaking in tongues. People dubbed it the million-dollar temple. Its auditorium sat 5,300 people in tiered stadium-style seating. The stage could accommodate a hundred-person choir, a full orchestra, and elaborate stage sets. And when people would look up,
如今，经过这么多年的努力，他们终于来为我们美丽的安吉拉斯教堂的劳作加冕。在1923年的元旦，麦克弗森开放了安吉拉斯教堂，这里是她命名为“四方福音教会”的事工所在地。里面有一个用于表演神迹医治的房间，一个充当全天候祈祷室的瞭望塔，一个专门用于说方言的房间。人们把它称为百万美元教堂。它的礼堂采用阶梯式体育场座位，可容纳5300人。舞台可以容纳百人唱诗班、全编制管弦乐队和精致的舞台布景。当人们抬头看时，
they would see that the ceiling was painted blue to look like the sky or the heavens and they were dotted with puffy clouds. Of course, extravagantly built houses of worship were not a new thing. They existed in many religions and many cultures. But in Protestant Christianity, there had been this belief since the 16th century
他们会看到天花板被涂成了蓝色，看起来像天空或天堂，上面点缀着蓬松的云朵。当然，奢华建造的礼拜堂并不是什么新鲜事。它们存在于许多宗教和许多文化中。但在新教基督教中，自16世纪以来一直有一种信念，即教堂应该小而简陋，因为那将象征着与上帝更亲密的关系。但艾米修女希望将大型、四处游走的帐篷复兴风格崇拜的精神活力和庞大信众永久地带入室内。在这样做的过程中，她帮助为所有在她之后的超级教堂绘制了蓝图。你知道的，如果你今天去一个超级教堂，就像这就是艾米所创新的，把这种盛大、喧闹、疯狂的大众崇拜搬到室内，而且每个星期都是如此。从教堂开放的那一刻起，安吉拉斯教堂的主日崇拜就大受欢迎，主要是因为麦克弗森上演了城里最好的表演。
that the church should be small and humble because that would signal a more intimate relationship with God. But Sister Amy wanted to bring the spirit energy and large congregation of the big, roving, tent revival style worship permanently indoors. And in doing so, she helped create the blueprint for all the megachurches that came after her. You know, if you go to a megachurch today, like that this is what Amy sort of innovated, of bringing this big, rowdy, wild mass worship inside and every Sunday. From the moment the temple opened, Sunday services at the Angeles Temple were an instant hit, mostly because McPherson put on the best show in town.
她在布道中融入了大量的杂耍表演和好莱坞元素。所以她会做这些，它们被称为图解布道，但它们本质上就是，你知道的，我的意思是，就像早期的基督教娱乐。因为这里是洛杉矶，而L.A.在当时本质上是一个小镇。艾米修女能够接触到在电影界工作的人。她请来了好莱坞的舞台经理、布景设计师、灯光设计师和化妆师，将她的愿景变为现实。她会把，你知道的，狮子带到舞台上，骆驼，精致的布景，令人难以置信的服装，巨大的，你知道的，音乐戏剧制作。而艾米修女本人就是这一切迷人的核心。但现在它会说他走进他的房子。
She incorporated a lot of vaudeville, a lot of Hollywood, into her sermons. So she would do these, they were called illustrated sermons, but they were essentially, you know, I mean, like early Christian entertainment. Because this was Los Angeles and L.A. was at its core, a small town at the time. Sister Amy had access to people who worked in the movie business. She tapped Hollywood stage managers, set designers, lighting designers, and makeup artists to bring her vision to life. She would bring, you know, lions onto the stage, camels, elaborate sets, incredible costumes, huge, you know, musical theater productions. And Sister Amy herself was the riveting center of it all. But now that it will say he goes in his house.
好吧，我看到狼来了，但我并不害怕。当他走到房子前时，他说：“小猪小猪，让我进来好吗？”狼说：“凭着我圆圆的下巴，我绝不让你进来。”狼说：“好吧，那么？我要跳啊跳，我要呼呼吹，把你的房子吹倒。”麦克弗森经常在座无虚席的场馆里讲道。信众实在是太多了，以至于四方教会不得不周日增加第三场礼拜。
Well, I see the wolf coming, but I'm not afraid. And as he rises to the house, he says, Takey-wicky, will you let me in? He said, by my chubby chint-chin, I'll never let you in. And the wolf says, all right, then? I'll hop and I'll, pop and I'll blow your house in. McPherson was preaching to a packed house regularly. There were so many congregants that Foursquare had to add a third service on Sundays.
尽管教堂已经拥有5300个座位，但有时仍有超过7000名信众挤进安吉拉斯教堂。艾米修女本人正在成为洛杉矶的一个标志。你熟悉“赞美好莱坞”这首歌吗？这是安吉拉斯教堂遗产博物馆的首席讲解员丹·斯科特。是的，她实际上在那首歌里。所以它是一首“赞美哈里和伍德”，然后接着是“还有秀兰·邓波儿，艾米也同样知道……不，我试过你不会，你可能成了一只鸭子。赞美哈里和伍德。”尽管她极受欢迎并拥有当地名人的地位，但麦克弗森知道她能够接触到远比每周几千名洛杉矶人多得多的人。
And even though the temple already fit 5,300 seats, sometimes over 7,000 worshippers would cram into the Angeles Temple. Sister Amy herself was becoming a Los Angeles institution. Are you familiar with the hooray for Hollywood song? This is Dan Scott, head docent of the Angeles Temple Heritage Museum again. Yeah, she's actually in that song. So it's a hooray for Hollywood. would, da-da-da-da-da-da-da, and then later it goes,
因此在她开放安吉拉斯教堂的第二年，她还建造了自己的基督教广播电台，在那里她可以接触到远至夏威夷的追随者。我真的、真的很很高兴能有荣幸对广播听众讲话。安吉拉斯教堂，我自己作为教堂的牧师，是世界上第一座拥有广播电台的教堂。
and Shirley Temple, and Amy's equal to know, da' No, I'll try you'll not, you may be done a duck. Hooray for Harley and Wood. Despite her incredible popularity and status as a local celebrity, McPherson knew that she could reach far more people than a few
当那些闪亮的银塔在我们的教堂圆顶上方升起，将信息向东西南北闪耀时。我们的机遇和特权被数十万与我们的广播教堂听众联合起来的人扩大了。但现在有了一个……现场的礼拜仪式配合了布景、服装和灯光变换。但麦克弗森明白，通过广播，她可以同样有效地进行交流，因为声音在你的家中直接对你说话具有那种亲密感。
thousand Angelinos a week. So the year after she opened the Angelus Temple, she also built her very own Christian radio station where she could reach followers as far away as Hawaii. I'm very, very happy indeed to have the privilege of speaking to the radio audience. Angelus Temple, myself as pastor of the temple, was the first church in the world to own a radio station.
我在某处读到关于这个关于广播的早期理论，我非常喜欢。有人称它为你可以把手放在全美各地起居室的门把手上，这有点令人毛骨悚然。但这就像是这种想法，你知道的，我的意思是，人们可以被媒体触动。艾米·森普尔·麦克弗森将娱乐与宗教融合并向世界广播，为美国的电视布道主义创建了一个模板。你知道的，她并不是电视布道主义的创始人。威廉·舒尔茨再次说道。我认为非常恰当的说法是，如果没有艾米在20世纪初开辟的道路，电视布道和广播布道是不可想象的。
And when those shining silver towers were lifted up above our temple dome and flashed the message, east, west, north, and south. Our opportunity and privilege was broadened by hundreds of thousands of people who united with our radio church audience. But now with a to... In person, the services engaged with sets, costumes, and lighting changes. But McPherson understood that with the radio,
在她建立她的事工短短几年内，四方福音协会已经在南加州拥有了32个教堂分支，还有数十家其他教堂申请成为安吉拉斯教堂的附属机构。她还觉得有必要不断让教堂保持增长。这是超级教堂运动的标志性特征之一，即认为增长本身就是一种正面的好事。如果你的教堂在增长，你就是在传播上帝的国度，为了继续增长你需要增长，因为人们希望成为一个看起来正在蓬勃发展的事物的一部分。
she could communicate just as effectively because of the intimacy of hearing a voice speaking to you in your home. I read it somewhere about this early theory of radio, which I loved. Somebody called it that you could have your hand on the doorknob of living rooms across America, which is kind of creepy. But like this idea of like, you know, I mean, people could be touched by media. Amy Simple McPherson blended entertainment with religion and broadcast it out to the world, creating a template for America. Televangelism. You know, she's not the founder of televangelism. William Schultz, again. It would, I think, be very proper to say televangelism and radio evangelism would be unthinkable
但所有的增长都伴随着巨大的压力。麦克弗森保持着极其折磨人的日程安排。如果她不在扩张教堂，她就在教堂讲道；如果她不在教堂讲道，她就在广播电台；如果她不在广播电台，她就在照顾她的信众。作为一个处于权力地位的女性，她也承受着一种非常激烈的审视。她被自己创造的角色所困，
without the path blazed by Amy in the early 20th century. Within just a couple of years of establishing her ministry, the Four Square Gospel Association already had 32 church branches in Southern California, with dozens of other churches applying to become affiliates of the Angelus Temple. She also feels the need to just constantly keep the church growing. This is one of the defining features of the megachurch movement, the idea that growth itself is a positive good. If your church is growing, you're spreading God's kingdom, and you need to grow in order to continue growing because people want to be part of something. that seems to be booming.
她必须不断地维持这种外在形象，她必须不断地把自己推销为一个完美的女人，这最终变得极具破坏性。而这种自我毁灭以一些真正奇异的方式表现出来。当我们进入她的卧室时，这里的墙壁代表了她的绑架案，我相信你也听说过或读过关于它的事。休息过后，艾米修女的故事将转向丑闻。请继续关注我们。
But all of that growth came with an immense amount of pressure. McPherson kept an utterly grueling schedule. If she wasn't expanding the church, she was preaching at the temple. And if she wasn't preaching at the temple, she was on the radio. If she wasn't on the radio, she was tending to her congregants. She was also under a very intense kind of scrutiny as a woman in a position of power. She was trapped by the role she had created. that she constantly has to put up this front,
1926年，安吉拉斯教堂已经成为洛杉矶的一个机构大约三年了。艾米·森普尔·麦克弗森正处于她名气的巅峰，每周向成千上万的忠实信徒讲道。我想南加州大学曾做过一项调查，学生们将她列为他们能想到的最著名的前三名女性之一。那是克莱尔·霍夫曼。所以，你知道的，真正是一个家喻户晓的名字。但她承受的所有压力——要发展事工、要牧养其成员、要让他们保持娱乐——开始对她造成伤害。麦克弗森全天候为教会服务，没有任何隐私或独处时间。
that she constantly has to sell herself as a perfect woman, that ultimately becomes so destructive. And that self-destruction manifested in some truly bizarre ways. As we make our way into her bedroom, this wall here represents her kidnapping, which I'm sure you've heard about or read about too. After the break, Sister Amy's story takes a turn for the scandalous. Stay with us.
所以她开始感受到她名气的压力和她工作的负担。在很多日子里，她有1万、1.5万人来看她讲道。于是她开始做这样一套常规程序：她从市中心开车到威尼斯海滩，
In 1926, the Angeles Temple had been a Los Angeles institution for about three years. Amy Simple McPherson was at the height of her fame and preaching to thousands of devoted worshippers a week. I think there was a USC survey where, students named her as one of the top three most famous women that they could think of. That's Claire Hoffman again. So, you know, and really a household name. But all the pressure she was under to grow the ministry, to shepherd its members, to keep them entertained, was beginning to take a toll. McPherson made herself available at all hours to the church and had no privacy or solitude.
她在阳光下坐着，在海里游泳，并且构思她的布道词。这正是她在1926年5月18日做的事情。在这一天，麦克弗森正在写一篇名为《光明与黑暗》的布道词，这时她被一个她从未见过的男人和一个女人搭讪了。他们说：“麦克弗森夫人，你知道的，我们车里有个生病的婴儿。请你来看看并为她祈祷好吗？”作为一名信心医治者，麦克弗森非常习惯接到这类请求。天使教堂甚至专门有一个房间，用来放置被奇迹般治愈的人们留下的所有拐杖和轮椅。于是她跟着这对夫妇去他们的车里为他们生病的孩子祈祷。在后座上，她看到像一堆毯子，她想，哦，这一定是个婴儿。他们打开车门，她以为她要为婴儿祈祷，但相反她头部挨了一下，她的嘴被什么东西捂住，然后她就晕了过去。
So she is starting to feel the stress of her celebrity and the burdens of her. her job. She's got 10,000, 15,000 people coming to see her preach on a lot of days. And so she starts to do this routine where she drives down to Venice Beach from downtown and
麦克弗森在光天化日之下消失得无影无踪。艾米修女的数千名追随者对她的突然失踪感到悲痛欲绝，并展开了大规模的搜寻来找到她。由于担心她可能在太平洋溺水身亡，潜水员们仔细搜查了威尼斯海滩和圣莫尼卡的浅水区。他们甚至用炸药炸开水面，希望能让她的尸体浮出水面。一名潜水员在寻找她时不幸身亡。另一位悲痛欲绝的教堂成员陷入极度痛苦，以至于自溺身亡。但麦克弗森还活着。
she sits in the sun and she swims in the ocean and she works on her sermons. Which is exactly what she did on May 18, 1926. On this particular day, McPherson was writing a sermon called Light and
她醒来时，不知道过了多久，在一个类似可怕卧室的地方被锁在铁链上。她很快意识到自己被那对在海滩上接近她的夫妇绑架了。她曾说其中一个人被称为“墨西卡利玫瑰”（碰巧是当时一首著名的歌），还有一个叫史蒂夫的家伙。墨西卡利玫瑰和史蒂夫告诉她，她被软禁在墨西哥阿瓜普列塔附近的一个棚子里，他们要求索要50万美元的赎金来换取她的回归。连续几周，麦克弗森发现自己被拘束在床上，变得越来越神志不清。但有一次，她的绑架者留下她一个人去买杂货，她看到了机会。她解开手腕上的绳子，在一罐头的锯齿边缘上锯断了绳子，从而逃脱了。
darkness when she was approached by a man and a woman that she had never seen before. And they say, Mrs. McPherson, you know, we have a baby in the car who's sick. Will you please come and pray over her? As a faith healer, McPherson was very used to getting these kinds of requests. The Angel's Temple even had a dedicated room for all of the crutches and wheelchairs left behind by people who had been miraculously healed. So she followed the couple to their car to heal their sick child. In the back seat, she sees like a pile of blankets and she thinks, oh, this must be the baby. And they open up the door and she thinks she's going to pray for the baby, but instead she gets hit on the head and she has something put over her mouth and she passes out.
麦克弗森从一幅窗户逃跑，在酷热的墨西哥沙漠中奔跑了20英里。她最终偶然 stumbled 发现了一座小屋，在那里找到了帮助，然后立刻晕倒了。她被带到了美墨边境美国一侧的一家医院。麦克弗森已经失踪了一个多月，并被推定死亡。她的母亲明妮甚至在安吉拉斯教堂为她举行了一场追悼会。但在那场追悼会三天后，麦克弗森活着重新出现，基本毫发无伤，并准备讲述她的故事。所以，是的，这就是她的绑架案。我能问一个后续问题吗？
McPherson disappeared in broad daylight without a trace. Sister Amy's thousands of followers were stricken by her sudden disappearance and launched a massive search to find her. Fearing she may have drowned in the Pacific, divers combed the shallows of Venice Beach in Santa Monica. They even blasted the waters with dynamite hoping it might surface her body. One diver tragically died trying to find her. Another grieving church member became so distraught that she drowned herself. But McPherson was very much alive.
当然可以。此时，我的制作人维维安插话问了一个问题。这真的发生了吗？就像，这就是故事。你觉得这发生的几率是多少？1%。我的意思是，我是一名记者，所以我从不喜欢做绝对的断言。我的意思是，你永远不能说绝不，但这并没有发生。
She wakes up, she doesn't know how much later, in some kind of awful bedroom chained to a bed. She quickly realized that she had been kidnapped by that couple who had approached her on the beach. Somebody that she said was called Mexicali Rose, which happened to be a famous song at the time, and a guy named Steve. Mexicali Rose and Steve told her that she was being held captive in a shack near Agua Prieta, Mexico, and that they were demanding $500,000 ransom for her return. For weeks, McPherson found herself restrained to a bed growing more and more delirious. But at one point, her captors left her alone to get groceries, and she saw her chance. And she escaped by taking the ropes around her wrist and sawing them on a serrated edge of a can.
当麦克弗森回到洛杉矶时，她大肆宣扬她那段充满惊险的绑架、囚禁和逃亡之旅。但没过多久，人们就开始对她的说法产生怀疑。事实证明，有很多事情需要调查。执法部门立刻觉得：这根本说不通。她的绑架故事中存在许多漏洞。按照她自己的说法，她在酷热的索诺拉沙漠中走了20多英里。然而，当她被救援时，她的身体状况好得可疑。
McPherson fled through a window and ran 20 miles through the blistering Mexican desert. She eventually ended up stumbling across a small home where she found help and then immediately fainted. She was taken to a hospital on the American side of the border. McPherson had been missing for over a month and already presumed dead. Her mother Minnie had even held a memorial service for her at the Angeles Temple. But three days after that service, McPherson reappeared alive, mostly unscathed, and ready to tell her story. And so, yeah, that's her kidnapping. Can I ask a follow-up question that?
你知道的，她没有被晒伤，没有被割伤，没有瘀伤，她甚至没有要水喝。还有一个事实是，执法部门从未能在她声称逃脱的阿瓜普列塔找到那个棚子。相反，他们发现了其他暗示不同情况的证据。他们花了几天时间寻找她声称被困住的棚子，他们，你知道的，从未找到。他们找到了轮胎痕迹，更像是离她出现的地方半英里远，脚印与她当时穿的拖鞋相符。所以看起来像是她曾下过车，或者有人从车里下来，然后走到她出现的那片院子里。还有长期以来的流言称，麦克弗森与她KFSG电台的一名已婚广播工程师有染，这导致了一种理论：她根本没有去过墨西哥，而是藏在加州的情夫家里。
Yeah, of course. At this point, my producer Vivian chimed in with a question. Did that happen? Like, that's the story. What do you think are the chances of that happened? 1%. I mean, I'm a journalist, so I never like to say anything definitively. I mean, you can never say never, but it didn't happen.
很快，证人开始从四面八方站出来说，实际上，我们看到艾米不在墨西哥，而是在加州北部的滨海卡梅尔，你知道的，在那里她穿着伪装，住在媒体所称的“爱巢”里。还有其他几起证人目击事件和证据。随着其他细节被揭露，麦克弗森为了掩盖她的婚外情并保护她的名誉而捏造绑架故事的可能性越来越大。这场所谓的婚外情成为针对她调查的焦点。地方检察官最终指控麦克弗森捏造证据、作伪证以及密谋策划骗局。
When McPherson returned to Los Angeles, she trumpeted her harrowing journey of abduction, captivity, and escape. but it didn't take long for people to start questioning her account. It turns out there was a lot to investigate. Law enforcement immediately was just like, this doesn't add up. There were a number of holes in her kidnapping story. By her own account, she had been walking 20-plus miles in the blazing hot Sonoran Desert. Yet, when she was rescued, she was in suspiciously good physical shape.
于是他们进行了这场审前听证会，持续了数月之久，并创下了费用记录。它是洛杉矶历史上最昂贵的审判，直到曼森谋杀案之前都是如此。而且它每天都占据着头版。在她崛起期间，艾米修女一直是媒体的宠儿。但到了这个时候，全国各地的报纸都以残忍和厌女的方式反对她。他们审视她的外表、她的离婚、她脚踝的大小。然而这并不是完全快乐的，这一次天空中有了阴影，但我确信外面有很多人有他们自己的特定麻烦，只有我的麻烦不知怎么总是很不幸，它们总能登上头条。经历这一切，麦克弗森坚守她的故事，声称黑帮地下世界、腐败政客、撒旦和天主教徒都在密谋打倒她。
You know, she wasn't sunburned, she wasn't cut, she wasn't bruised, she didn't ask for water. There was also the fact that law enforcement was never able to locate the shack in Agua Prieta that she claimed she escaped from. Instead, they found other evidence that suggested something else. They spent days looking for the shack that she said she was trapped in and they, you know, they never found it. They found tire marks more like a half a mile from where she showed up with footprints that matched, you know, the slippers she was wearing. So it looked like she had gotten, somebody had gotten out of a car and kind of walked over to the yard where she appeared. There were also longstanding rumors that McPherson was having an affair with a married radio engineer at her station, KFSG, which led to a theory that she hadn't been in Mexico at all, but hiding out with her lover in California.
麦克弗森遭受了针对她信誉的全面攻击，情况看起来相当严峻。但令人惊讶的是，在调查大约一个月后，麦克弗森收到了一个对她故事的不寻常辩护。不幸的是，对于麦克弗森来说，辩护将以法律史上最不可信的证人之一的形式出现，一个名叫洛林·怀斯曼-希利夫的女人。洛林·怀斯曼-希利夫就像一个我觉得只能存在于20世纪20年代的角色。你知道的，她经历过铁路事故，有点精神失常。她曾进出过疯人院，就像是一个投机取巧、骗子类型的人，可能也患有精神分裂症，并且还有一个双胞胎姐姐。检察官关于麦克弗森行踪的主要理论是她和情夫藏在卡梅尔。
Soon witnesses started to kind of come out of the woodwork and say, like, actually, we saw Amy not in Mexico, but in. in northern California in Carmel by the sea, you know, where she was wearing a disguise and living in what the press called a love shack. There were several other witness sightings and pieces of evidence. And as other details were uncovered, it became more and more likely that McPherson had concocted the kidnapping story in order to conceal her affair
但怀斯曼-希利夫出现在安吉拉斯教堂，声称在卡梅尔被目击的神秘女性不是麦克弗森，而是怀斯曼-希利夫本人。而艾米觉得：太棒了，好极了。这是一个如此方便的反转故事，麦克弗森立刻抓住了这个机会。她实际上把怀斯曼-希利夫搬进了安吉拉斯教堂的牧师住宅，以便她可以指导怀斯曼-希利夫寻找方法使她的供词看起来更有说服力。后来真相大白，原来麦克弗森和怀斯曼-希利夫一直在密谋串通，这引发了又一场媒体风暴。但到头来，其实也无所谓了。
and protect her reputation. This alleged affair became the focal point of an investigation against her. And the district attorney ended up Charging McPherson with fabricating evidence, lying under oath, and conspiracy to commit a hoax. So they do this pretrial hearing, which takes months, and set records for its cost. It was the most expensive trial in Los Angeles's history until the Manson murders. And it was just every day on the front pages. During her assent, Sister Amy had been a darling of the media.
对麦克弗森的指控在案件甚至还没进入审判之前就被驳回了，因为没有足够的证据证明她没有被绑架，而且洛杉矶的官员们由于这起案件引起的媒体马戏团效应，迫切想要摆脱这个案子。这确实是一场马戏团，里面充满了各种荒诞的细节，我们甚至无法在这个故事中全部展开，例如据称是她绑架者的唯一另一个证人，首先，是一位与麦金利总统有亲戚关系的盲人律师，但随后他在正准备提供进一步证据时在车祸中死于水沟——死在一英尺深的水中。明白我的意思了吗？至于艾米修女和美国的第一个超级教堂，奇怪的是，尽管她的名字在每个头条中都被泼了脏水，
But by this point, newspapers all over the country had. turned against her in cruel and misogynistic ways. They scrutinized her appearance, her divorce, the size of her ankles. It isn't completely happy, however, this time there are shadows in the sky, but I'm sure that many people out there have their own particular troubles, only mine are always somehow unfortunate, they seem to get into the headlines. Through it all, McPherson stuck by her story, claiming the CD gangster underworld, corrupt politicians, Satan, and the Catholics were all plotted.
整场风波最终对教堂来说竟然是一件好事。安吉拉斯教堂实际上在丑闻期间发展壮大了。把它归入“没有所谓的坏宣传”这类文件里。但在她的名气方面，我的意思是，这是一个开始涌现出那些开始体现某种单一类型人物的时代的时代，比如贝比·鲁斯作为运动员，或者查尔斯·林德伯格作为冒险家。艾米就是传道人。
to take her down. McPherson suffered an onslaught against her credibility and things were looking pretty grim. But surprisingly, about a month into the investigation, McPherson was presented with an unusual defense to her story. Unfortunately for McPherson, the defense would come in the form of one of the least credible witnesses in legal history, a woman named Lorraine Weissman-Seeliff. And Lorraine Wiseman-Seeliff is like a character that I feel like could only exist in the 1920s. You know, she had had a railroad accident and kind of lost her mind. She'd been in, you know, lunatic houses and was like a, you know, kind of hustler, scam artists who maybe also was schizophrenic and who had a twin sister. The district attorney's leading theory for McPherson's whereabouts was that she had been hiding out in Carmel with her lover.
你知道的，暂停一下，外展服务真是不可思议。我的意思是，在20世纪30年代初，曾有过一年她对超过两百万人发表过讲话。你知道的，安吉拉斯教堂和艾米在大萧条期间处于公共服务的中心。他们，你知道的，帮助安置流离失所的人。我的意思是，这真是太不可思议了。但她确实搞砸了，简直是巨大的砸。
But Wiseman Seeliff showed up to the Angelus Temple claiming that the mysterious woman spotted in Carmel wasn't McPherson. but Wiseman Seeliff herself. And Amy's like, fantastic, great. This was such a convenient counter story that McPherson leapt at the opportunity. She actually moved Wiseman Seeliff into the parsonage of the Angelus Temple so that she could coach Wiseman Seeliff
但与此同时，她也取得了如此巨大的成就。在接下来的几十年里，四方事工不断扩张，但麦克弗森本人却在挣扎。她遭受了健康不佳、糟糕的财务决策、诉讼、一段可疑的第三次婚姻的折磨，并最终与她生命中最亲近的两个人——她自己的母亲和女儿——形同陌路。1944年9月27日，麦克弗森在奥克兰进行一系列复兴聚会时，一切都画上了句号。她发表了她最著名的讲道之一——《我的一生》，那天晚上她回到了酒店。她和儿子在一起，身上带着无法追溯来源的处方药瓶。她吞下了整瓶药，或者很大一部分，然后她就去世了。
on ways to make her appear more convincing. It eventually came out that McPherson and Weissman Seeliff had been conspiring with one another, which caused yet another media storm. But in the end, it didn't really, really matter. The charges against McPherson were dismissed before they ever went to trial because there wasn't quite enough evidence to prove that she wasn't kidnapped, and officials in Los Angeles were desperate to be rid of this case because of the media circus it had caused. And it truly was a
关于如何让她看起来更有说服力的方法。后来真相大白，麦克弗森和韦斯曼·西利夫串通一气，这引发了又一场媒体风暴。但到头来，其实并没有那么重要。针对麦克弗森的指控在开庭审判前就被驳回了，因为没有足够的证据来证明她没有被绑架，而且洛杉矶的官员们迫切希望甩掉这个案子，因为这起案件引起的媒体风暴太疯狂了。这确实是一场
circus with all sorts of unhinged details that we couldn't even get into for this story, such as the sole alleged other witness to her kidnappers was, first of all, a blind attorney. who was related to President McKinley, but that then he dies just as he's about to give, like, further evidence in a car accident where he drowns in a ditch of, like, one foot of water. See what I mean? As for Sister Amy and America's first megachurch, oddly enough, even with her name being dragged through the mud and every headline,
马戏团般的闹剧，里面有各种各样神经错乱的细节，我们甚至无法在这期节目中一一展开，比如她绑架案中唯一的另一个据称目击者，首先，是一位盲人律师，他与麦金莱总统有亲戚关系，但随后就在他准备提供进一步证据时，在一场车祸中丧生了，他在只有一英尺深的水沟里溺水身亡。明白我的意思了吧？至于艾米修女和美国的第一座巨型教堂，说来也奇怪，尽管她的名誉扫地，而且充斥着各种头条新闻，
the whole debacle ended up being great for the church. Angelus Temple actually grew, during the scandal. Put that in the, there's no such thing as bad publicity files. But in terms of her fame, I mean, this was an era
整场惨败最终对教堂来说反而是一件好事。在丑闻期间，天使庙实际上还发展壮大了。把它归入“没有所谓的负面宣传”这类档案里吧。但就她的名气而言，我的意思是，这是一个
where he started to have the emergence of these figures who come to embody like a single type, like Babe Ruth, right, as the athlete or Charles Lindberg
开始出现一些能够代表某一特定类型人物的时代的，比如贝比·鲁斯作为运动员，或者查尔斯·林德伯格
as the adventurer. Amy was the preacher. You know, and just to pause, like, the outreach is incredible. You know, I mean, there were, there was a year in the early 1930s where she spoke to over two million people. You know, she was, you know, the Angela's Temple and Amy were at the center of public service during the Great Depression. They, you know, helped house people. I mean, it was, it was incredible. But she definitely screwed up, like mega, you know.
作为冒险家。艾米就是传教士。你知道的，稍作停顿，她的外展活动简直不可思议。你知道，20世纪30年代初，曾有一年的时间，她向两百 多万人发表过演讲。你知道，在大萧条时期，天使庙和艾米成为了公共服务的中心。她们帮助安置人们。我的意思是，这真是太不可思议了。但她确实搞砸了，而且是大错特错。
But at the same time, she accomplished so much. For the next couple of decades, the Foursquare ministry expanded, but McPherson herself struggled. She suffered from poor health, poor financial decisions, lawsuits, a questionable third marriage, and ultimately became estranged from her own mother and daughter, the two closest people in her life. On September 27, 1944, McPherson was in Oakland for a series of revival meetings when it all came to an end. She gives one of her most famous sermons, the story of my life, and she goes home that night to the hotel. She's with her son and had bottles of prescription medicine that they can't trace to where she got them. And she took the whole bottle, or a lot of it, and she died.
但与此同时，她也取得了巨大的成就。在接下来的几十年里，四方福音事工不断扩展，但麦克弗森本人却举步维艰。她饱受健康状况不佳、糟糕的财务决策、诉讼、一段可疑的第三次婚姻的困扰，最终与她生命中最亲近的两个人——她的母亲和女儿疏远了。1944年9月27日，麦克弗森在奥克兰进行一系列复兴聚会时，这一切走到了尽头。她发表了她最著名的布道之一——《我的一生》，当晚她回到了酒店。她和儿子在一起，身上有几瓶处方药，但无法追查来源。她服用了整瓶药，或者大部分，然后她去世了。
Even after McPherson died, her church continued to live on and grow. There are thousands of four-square churches around the world today, with millions of men. members. But while followers may remember Amy Simple McPherson as an important religious figure for those not in the church, she is more likely to be remembered for the scandal and tragic end to her life, if at all. You really have to understand she was like a forerunner of getting that from like kind of the fringe of religion into the mainstream. You know, now there are 600 million Pentecostals in the world. It's a quarter of the world's Christians. It has moved from the absolute fringe, the mainstream,
即使在麦克弗森去世后，她的教会依然存活并发展壮大。如今，世界各地有数千座四方教会，拥有数百万名成员。然而，虽然信徒们可能将埃米·森普尔·麦克弗森视为一位重要的宗教人物，但对于教会之外的人来说，她更可能因其丑闻和悲惨的结局而被记住，如果还能被记住的话。你真的必须明白，她就像是一个先行者，把这种边缘宗教带入了主流。你知道，现在世界上有6.05亿五旬节派信徒。这占世界基督徒的四分之一。它已经从绝对的边缘走向了主流，
and she's a big part of that story. So we can go down the mezzanine here. Watch your step. Let me just show you what it used to look like, though, when sister was here. Now it's very plain Jane. But when she was here, it was quite lovely. Walking around the Angelus Temple, it's clear that the building itself is a long way from its opulent beginnings.
而她正是这个故事的重要部分。所以我们可以顺着这里的夹层下去。当心脚下。不过，让我给你们看看当“修女”在这里时，它是什么样子的。现在这里非常朴素。但当她在这里时，它是相当迷人的。走在天使庙里，很明显，这座建筑本身已经远非其奢华的初创时期可比。
The church has had to evolve with modern culture, but modernization in many ways has sanded away some of the details that made this building singular. The prayer tower is now an HVAC room. The iconic KFSG station was sold to help pay for a parking structure. The 100-person choir has been traded in for contemporary music. Even that heavenly sky blue dome designed to evoke the outdoor revival is now obscured by sound-absorbing panels. Because with the newer modern drums and keyboards and electric guitars for the music and the worship, this room was terrible. It just caused a lot of noise. It may be a bit more subdued these days, but the Angeles Temple makes for a fitting monument to the woman who built it.
这座教会不得不随着现代文化而演变，但在许多方面，现代化抹去了一些让这座建筑独一无二的细节。祈祷塔现在成了暖通空调房。标志性的KFSG电台被卖掉，以支付停车场的建设费用。100人的唱诗班被换成了现代音乐。甚至那个旨在唤起户外复兴的天蓝色穹顶，现在也被吸音板遮挡了。因为有了更新潮的现代鼓、键盘和用于音乐与崇拜的电吉他，这个房间的音响效果变得极差。这只会产生太多的噪音。如今这里或许更加低调一些，但天使庙依然是为建造它的那位女性树立的一座恰如其分的纪念碑。
Enormously influential, half forgotten, and even after all these years, still begging to be noticed. My precious Lord Has a won my heart 99% Invisible was reported this week by Gileon Jacobs, produced by Vivian Lay and edited by Kelly Prime, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real and George Langford, fact-checking by Graham Hesha. And special thanks this week to Bix Davis and Richard Florey.
影响力巨大，却已被半遗忘，而且在经历了这么多年后，依然渴望得到关注。我亲爱的救主已赢得我的心。《99%隐形》本周由吉利翁·雅各布斯报道，维维安·莱伊制作，凯利·普赖姆剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，天鹅真实乐队和乔治·兰格福德提供音乐，格雷厄姆·赫沙负责事实核查。本周要特别感谢比克斯·戴维斯和理查德·弗洛里。
Claire Hoffman's book is called Sister Center, The Miraculous Life and Mysterious Disappearance of Amy Simple McPherson. It is such a fun read. It's packed with lots of juicy details that we couldn't fit into this episode, so you should definitely check it out. Kathy, too, is our executive producer. Kurt Colestead is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, La Cheshemadon, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
克莱尔·霍夫曼的书名为《修女中心：埃米·森普尔·麦克弗森的奇迹人生与神秘失踪》。这本书读起来非常有趣。里面包含了许多我们无法塞进本集的精彩细节，所以你绝对应该去读一读。凯茜·图是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。德兰妮·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉·切谢马顿、乔·罗森伯格、雅各布·梅迪纳·吉利森以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。
We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. my lording home. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于北边六个街区外的潘多拉大楼。在美丽、繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有一个链接，以及99PI过去每一集的链接，网址是99PI.org。我亲爱的主的家。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。